since
2003 uh
after 2003 i used to to play the
swashnikov
quite a bit um
i think at first i almost regarded it as
a bit of a
cheat code in local tournaments
because
most norwegians or in general people or
around tournaments they would
they would go
um
they would go for an early um
let me just see they would go for an
early bishop takes f6
so what they would do is they would
play these positions and they would
would usually not have um
too much of a clue what to do for some
reason and then
despite being this the the sharpest line
uh yeah and you would go f5 and you
would
get a huge center so that was my
experience
playing these games that
usually when when i got the switch to go
i would steamroll people uh were you
more inclined to study sharp theory in
long lines at that point in your chest
career i guess to some extent um it took
yeah it took a little while before i
took up the swastika but in general
um
the way that you could apparently get
very interesting sharp positions
so early on um it appealed appealed to
me um
that's that's for uh that's for sure um
so what i what i think happened over
time is that
people would more and more often choose
these lines with uh knight d5 which
leads to
to a lot more uh positional play which
sort of um
uh and also three bishop b5 uh or three
knight c3 which sort of um
yeah put a dent in the appeal of of the
swashnikov as well
i think
this game
more than anything else
shows the
um
what black house actually has to go
through it to create winning chances in
this particular
because you really had to throw the
kitchen so yeah i really i really did
have and which is one of the things that
makes me
pretty uh proud of this game even to to
this day yeah i gotta say this is one of
my favorite games in the course and uh
we'll talk about it during the game but
playing around that night on d5 and the
constant strategic threat that night
presents is an important theme
so i guess we'll start here
f after bishop d8
and
this is the start of
um i said before we started that this is
one of my favorite themes
and i think
for many years i've been trying to argue
that the bishop on d8 dominates the
knight of d5
uh in some of these cases
that
often i feel that
for one
the bishop protects
all
uh all of the
forward squares for for for the night
and
also
the night
whenever the night moves the bishop
becomes active
immediately
in this particular case at least at this
moment is uh it's a major
exaggeration um
probably at this point the night is
better but the game shows that it's
possible
possible to to play around it
and just for context can you show the
queen e8 move too
yeah
so what happened is
i made the move queen yet
for a few reasons i wanted to get the
queen out of the attack uh obviously i
wanted to be able to
harmoniously um
regroup the bishop to to d8
and
besides if the queen goes to d8 it
cannot go to g6 so what i would want at
some point to do is to go king h8 then
go f5
uh recapture on f5 and then put the
queen actively on on on d6 so i just
think that's such a telling moment
because one of the hallmarks of great
players is they'll play moves that
visually to a weaker player look awkward
i mean queen e8 you're boxing in the
rook looks like knight c7 is floating in
the air even though you're hitting the
rook on a4 twice of course
yeah that was kind of cool how that set
up your next move bishop d8 yeah um
i think
to me at that point i played a bit of
sashnikov so i it was um
it was very clear to me that that's the
way i needed to
to redeploy the the pieces but uh yeah i
do think
it's it's uh it's telling that
um when when deciding where to retreat
the queen you should not only think of
what looks more logical right now which
i agree to some extent just queen the a
to protect
you protect a5 and you
uh prepare moving the the rook later on
but
um the uh i yeah preparing the
apparently passive
bishop retreat i think is preparing to
try to
approve of your theory yeah about the
bishop dominating life yeah um okay so
we move forward bishop to d8
castles
and and rook c8 so i'm just trying to
discoordinate him
a bit which is uh which is a theme here
um
um it should be said that in no way is
black better here
i'm still sort of objectively speaking
um
fighting a little bit for for equality
like for instance
if he goes b3 i'm gonna go a4 just get
rid of that weak pawn but this is not
really
um a winning try after i take on b3
the position would be fairly
fairly equal and it liquidates a little
bit yeah it liquidates but
that would be just i think too little um
on the board to
[Music]
to
seriously hope for hope for a win but i
think smith was was still a bit
optimistic so he went for bishop e3